hey welcome to this
morning session
um
the
first and second lecture will be given
by
katie craig
who is
the faculty assistant professor at uc
santa barbara
so katie obtained her phd in 2014
at graduate university with uh eric
carlin
my former colleague
then she held an nsf postdoc position
at ucla
and uh also she got the
uc presidential
postdoc fellowship before joining the
faculty
at uc santa barbara
so today she will talk about uh
gradient point pd
thank you very much um thank you very
much for that introduction and for
inviting me here to give this
introductory lecture and my goal is
going to really make it introductory i
know there are a lot of people at this
conference from a variety of backgrounds
optimization sampling as well as pde so
i hope that there will be something in
this lecture uh for everyone
um so i'd like to begin this lecture on
pde with a little bit of motivation as
to why you might be interested in pdes
if you're not already for example if you
come from a background
where you typically deal with more
spatially discrete objects
um so i'm going to begin by just giving
you a few examples of some pdes
that might be of interest to you
so throughout my talk i'm going to be
all of the pdes that i mentioned are
going to be describing the evolution of
a density rho
rho is going to depend on space and time
and you can think of my variable x as
just a vector in rd
all of the equations i describe are
going to be
all the equations i talk about are going
to be describing the evolution of rho
thinking of rho as a type of density for
example a density of particles at
location x in time t
uh so the most you know fundamental
equation that i'll of all that i'll
mention um is the continuity equation
so the continuity equation is just says
that the time derivative of rho
plus the divergence of some given
velocity field v v can depend on both
space and time
times rho equals zero
and we typically think of this as an
initial value problem so we prescribe
the uh
the density at time zero
and then we want to see what happens
over time when the density evolves
according to this pde
and you know it's given that i've stated
this at such a level of generality that
you can pick whichever velocity field
you like um solutions of this equation
uh can look uh like lots of different
things maybe the simplest example to
draw would be a velocity field that's
just identically equal to one for all
space and time
and in this case uh if i start off with
some initial density that looks like
that over time it's just going to
shift to the right
um so this is uh
this overly simple example is just
showing that the continuity equation you
know matches your intuition of what
an equation like this should be doing
it's really describing how a density of
particles moves over time according to
this velocity in this case the velocity
just says shift to the right
okay so um something that's nice about
the continuity equation and uh
is that it has a
a useful discretization from a particle
perspective um in particular you could
think about a associated ordinary
differential equation um
so i'm gonna now be thinking about um
uh
uh the evolution of
in particles
um and i'll think of these as particles
in euclidean space
and i
if i evolve these particles according to
this ordinary differential equation
and again i have some
initial conditions
uh then it turns out there's a close
correspondence between this system of
odes so i have one ode for each of my in
particles and solutions of this pde
in particular if the velocity field the
sort of fixed velocity field i have v x
of t is sufficiently nice and for
example if it's you know globally lit
shits um in space
then as long as the initial conditions
for this particle system are
approximating the initial conditions for
the pde so in other words
if i take the
empirical measure at each of these
locations
as long as those locations you know
converge in some sense for example in
the vessel's diametric as n goes to
infinity
to this initial data i was thinking
about at the pda level then it turns out
the evolving empirical measure where i
now take these dirac masses and i let
their locations evolve according to this
pde
converges again in some sense for
example a phosphorous diametric
to
the continuum solution of my pde
okay so um because of this close
connection um between um the pde in this
particle interpretation um a lot of the
pd's i mentioned today are going to have
a natural discretization of the particle
level um which will hopefully have a
better intuition for those who come from
a discrete background
two things that i uh neglected to
mention at the very beginning
that key properties of uh this pde that
kind of make this particle method a bit
more reasonable for it is it turns out
that if you start with a if you have a
solution of this pde where the initial
condition is non-negative it will remain
non-negative for all time so i'm always
going to assume that my
densities are non-negative
and furthermore
this pde conserves mass so whatever the
integral of the initial data is that
integral will be preserved over time um
so in other words this
is constant in time over the evolution
of the pde and so uh for simplicity i'm
going to normalize all of my equations
so that equals one
um and so this is where start
probability measures start to appear or
in this case i'm just writing it as a
probability density uh so it's not
necessarily that i have anything
stochastic going on at this point it's
just that it's a non-negative density
that integrates to one um is where the
kind of connection to probability
densities first appears um because this
is an introductory talk i'm going to
mostly be writing my rows as probability
densities um but a lot of what i say
also works for probability measures if
you're happy to kind of you know make
some abuses of notation
okay so this was the simplest equation
that i wanted to mention the kind of
fundamental building block for a lot of
the other equations i'll talk about um
but in general this equation is not a
vosserstein gradient flow um for just an
arbitrary velocity field and so now
let's focus in on the specific type of
continuity equation that that uh say it
again yes
quick questions
um what is sort of the typical like
order of convergence of this statement
is it something like one over square
root
um it would depend on okay so it'll it
just depends a little bit on the
regularity of the velocity field um so
if your velocity field let's say is
globally lipschitz um
then you could get
uh an error
it'll depend on the rate of at which
so the estimate that you can get
is that you can get something like
the difference between
the empirical measure
at time t
and the exact solution
of the
continuity equation will be bounded
according to a constant
that depends on
time so we're talking about in time
intervals here
um it depends on this
uh global lipschitz estimate on on the
velocity field
and
and then the
vessel sign distance between the initial
data so um it'll depend on kind of how
if you want to get a rate in terms of n
then you'll need to say by what method
you're sampling uh the initial data like
how's that scaling in
and okay often in practice this is way
too strong of an assumption that that's
globally legit so you can say lots of
things in in without that assumption but
this is something that you can say at a
high level of generality
okay so um so now let's talk about a
specific equation that is a vosserstein
gradient flow and this is equation
that's attracted a lot of interest over
the past 20 years and i'll call it an
aggregation equation with drift
so now we're looking at the evolution of
a density
according to two terms
one is going to be this
external drift potential
and another is going to be an
interaction potential
uh in equations of this form show up a
lot in applications um you know the the
drift potential
can be a lot of different things it's a
fixed function at x and
uh from a mathematical perspective that
one doesn't give us too much trouble um
what really gives us a lot of trouble is
this interaction potential especially
since the interaction potentials that
show up in applications
can have singularities like for example
the positive or negative newtonian
potential this shows up in models of
vortex motion in superconductors and
biological chemotaxis
or another example would be these types
of attractive repulsive interaction
potentials
that show up in models of biological
swarming
okay so um this is the term that gives
us trouble
um so what is this what are the dynamics
that this pde describes well it says
that my density on one hand wants to
evolve so this is again a continuity
equation where the velocity is just
given by the gradient of capital v so my
but you see i've moved it to the other
side of the equation so i guess the
velocity is negative the gradient of
capital v
so my function rho wants to evolve down
the gradient and the directs negative
the gradient of capital v and then this
term
this velocity field here uh really
causes the density to interact with
itself um so for example depending on
your choice of w like the sort of
repulsive attractive one this will cause
the density to repel itself at short
short length scales that attract itself
at long length scales and that shows up
in models of biological swarming for
example if you imagine a flock of birds
the birds repel each other at short
length scales they don't want to crash
into each other but they're attracting
each other at long length scales they
want to form a cohesive block
okay so um
this equation has been studied by so
many authors i will mention just two
papers that were fundamental to its uh
vosserstein gradient flow structure or
two a book first is the book by ambrosia
julian savare and the second is the
paper by carrillo di francesco figally
laurent and snapchat
um so like the continuity equation um
that we were talking about just a moment
ago uh this pde has a corresponding
particle discretization
um
so if you come from the discrete side of
things this uh may give you a better
insight into what dynamics i'm talking
about here
so the each
particle evolves according to this
ordinary differential equation
and here
you see how
in a sense the density is interacting
with itself or the particles are
interacting with each other um uh
through this term
uh like i promised this equation does
have a vascular sign gradient flow
structure it turns out to be the
gradient flow of this energy
the energy has an external potential
term
uh and what we call an interaction
potential term
and especially at the particle level you
can sort of see why this is true the
particles are going in the direction of
negative the gradient of the energy so
or of the of this external potential
capital v so somehow they're they're
they're going to where that capital v is
small and that's exactly what's going to
be making this energy smaller
okay so why do i mention this example of
the pde well uh for a vessel saying
gradient flow first it's because when um
where the the theory is very mature at
this point um and second is because it's
going to have some eq connections with
other pdes i'll mention in a moment um
and i think it could be interesting
when studying those other pdes that you
know arise
in context and machine learning or
sampling topics close to the heart of
this workshop
to consider what has been done in the
classical theory in this case
in particular something i really like
about this equation is that while the
particle dynamics do give you a lot of
intuition for what's going on at the
level of the pde
by considering solutions of the pde
you're actually considering a richer
class of dynamics and is just accessible
by particles like particles just are
just telling you what happens if you
evolve an empirical measure according to
this equation but you can actually you
know take a much wider range of initial
data um and something you know that's
known in the theory of this level is
that the regularity of your initial data
and then the subsequent regularity of
solutions to your pde can actually give
you better convexity properties in a
weak sense of the energy and so if you
want to get good stability properties of
your gradient flow it could be worth
going to the level of the pde
considering a broader types of solutions
maybe solutions in a different
regularity class than just empirical
measures
um and then
you know often we
have to get back to something discrete
in order to put it into a computer but
there's a whole field of numerical
analysis of pdes to help you with that
um so i i guess the reason i wanted to
mention this example is just to advocate
that the the pde perspective really can
bring more than you just see from the
particle perspective
oh thank you i accidentally wrote an x
instead of a y there
yes yes w so capital w does depend on
the on both variables but not on the
difference only can you also say
something about the grading flow does it
look similar uh
just could i i will get to an example
like that in just a moment yeah so that
is a good point that the the
my function w here only depends on x and
y through their difference and and that
makes this the theory for this um much
easier than the theory when it depends
on x and y individually
um
okay great so so this is the second
example of a type of gradient flow um
something that is maybe of interest if
you're coming from um applied
mathematics
uh
another example of a vossenstein
gradient flow that we've seen many times
uh throughout the conference already is
of course the focker funk equation which
describes the evolution of a density
according to we have
a drift term here notice this is the
same external potential as above um
and diffusion
uh this has a corresponding particle
method in this case because we have
diffusion present it's a stochastic
particle method
uh
uh and
got my gradient
and interestingly um even at the level
of this you know stochastic particle
method you can still come back and and
make uh improve something like the same
statement that i said at the beginning
if you take solutions of the stochastic
particle method and consider the
empirical measure it turns out that it
will converge almost surely to a
solution of the pde um so this
perspective even works um
in the stochastic case
and then again this is
truly a gradient flow in the phosphorous
died metric because this first term is
the same as the first term we saw above
it shouldn't surprise you that the first
term and the energy will also be the
same
and then the second term uh in the
energy is just
uh
the
the entropy or or the negative entropy
depending on if you're coming from kind
of the
information theory or physics background
okay and so this again makes sense this
energy makes sense corresponding to the
dynamics of this pde because this says
that the density should be going towards
you know down the gradient of v so it'll
be making that smaller and then this
says that the density is spreading out
and so we'll be making the
entropy smaller
okay um and the the vasa sign gradient
flow in the perspective of the vocker
plunk equation um has been very
productive in the past few years um
because
it basically uh by understanding
convexity properties of this uh function
v
tells you about convexity properties of
the energy landscape here in the vaser
stein sense that's driving these
dynamics and from the convexity
properties of the energy landscape you
can recover all of the beautiful
properties you might want of the focker
plunk equation when v is strongly convex
you know for example contraction of
solutions exponential convergence to
equilibrium log sub 11 equalities uh so
it's sort of a nice unifying perspective
for a lot of one these wonderful
properties of the thakura punk equation
yes
so
if i were to write degree in flow of
this energy i would get
by default something which is
deterministic and you write it as some
something sarcastic so you have choices
when you actually choose your particle
evolution so
here is that the one you picked is there
a particular reason you want the
parameters of it to be time independent
no i it was arbitrary so um so but this
is a good point thank you for
emphasizing this um there's a key
difference between this this equation
and this equation up here the particle
evolution here if i look at the
empirical measure according spot
corresponding to this it is actually a
weak solution of that pde it is actually
a phosphorous time gradient flow of this
energy whereas if i do the particle that
if i do the empirical measure according
to this it is not actually a volcanic
gradient flow of this energy um and so
you're right that here i have some
choice um and the reason why is because
i could write that pde as a continuity
type equation you know we've
um
you can
factor things
um so that we write it as negative grad
v
um
uh
plus negative grad row
over row
uh
now i'm going to put all of this in
zero okay so i could write it as like a
continuity equation where this is my
velocity field
um but you can see that this is a pretty
weird velocity field in particular for
general rho this is not gonna have a
global uh
global ellipses and so because of that
the particle method is not going to be
well defined in particular if you if you
wanted to try to find an empirical
measure solution to this pde you start
off with initial data that's the sum of
direct masses instantaneously in time
it's not going to be a sum of direct
masses and so so the the kind of
particle perspective which is so nice um
in in the case above because of the
presence of diffusion here and its
smoothing effects it breaks down and so
there exactly i just picked you know a
different particle um interpretation of
this ppe
yes so even more basic questions
are there are the rules for deriving the
product representation from the pde or
is your goal just to invent a particle
representation that has this property of
convergence of an
i would say um at the level of up here
yes there are rules for deriving it and
it's it's just the exact uh rule that i
mentioned up here if your velocity field
is sufficiently nice
you just take the od with the same
velocity field so it's pretty not
creative rule um
but uh but indeed the problem is is that
in practice
we care about many equations where the
velocity field doesn't satisfy a nice
enough property
for this system of odes to be well posed
and so then things start to break down
okay so you have to exercise some
creativity in deriving the particle yes
exactly
but that's good that keeps people like
me busy so no creativity was involved
you know i would be very bored
um
okay so um another example um which is
you know been worked on uh extensively
by um many people affiliated with this
conference um in in recent years it was
identified that models of two-layer
neural networks um in the mean field
scaling regime um can be studied using
the studied using these vosperstein
gradient flow techniques um unlike above
where i've been very systematically
writing the pde the particles and the
energy here i'm actually just going to
write the energy because
the pd's and the particles get a little
messy um so the energy in this case i'm
just going to write one specific choice
of energy i'm going to write the one
coming from the quadratic loss that's
because it has a nice parallel with the
energy i spoke of earlier
and so i have some activation function
capital phi x of z
i have a parameter function or a
parameter measure
row of x dx
i have a target function that i'm trying
to approximate f naught of z
and then i have a data distribution d
new
and a lot of different activation
functions are used in practice
for example i will just mention
uh the
the relu activation function
and a radial basis function activation
function
okay so um in this case basically what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
pick uh your parameters row so that this
parametrizes your target function as
accurately as possible when measured in
this sense kind of the the quadratic
loss with respect to a given data
distribution
um and so you know what was identified
in many works by uh montenarian nguyen
rosco fendenandon uh shizab bach and
many others is that um the way that you
evolve these parameters in practice if
you use the mean field scaling
convention is exactly to evolve rho
according to the foster stein gradient
flow of this energy
um so uh the reason why i chose this you
know specific case for today's
introductory lecture lecture the sun
quadratic loss is because in this case
you can expand the square and it turns
out to look something uh very much like
what leona was just asking about a
moment ago
so i'm going to expand the square and
the first term that i'm going to get
i'm going to expand the square and i'm
going to blindly apply fubini so i'm
going to change my orders of
integration
so the quadratic term
in the square i
i'm going to also you know
introduce a new variable since i would
have to
rather than writing x twice i'm going to
call the other x y
the quadratic term looks like this
first quadratic term i guess
then the cross term
uh would look like this
and then the final term i actually don't
care about because this doesn't depend
on my density on my on my measure row so
it's just constant in row and so when
i'm doing gradient descent and row that
constant will go away
okay so why did i kind of do this
somewhat messy looking expansion it's
just to point out that now here i have a
function of x and y and now here
i have a function
all right
and so suddenly this is exactly the same
type of form as the energy that i
mentioned a moment ago where the theory
of also saying gradient flows is very
well developed with the key distinction
that leon pointed out that this depends
on x and y separately as opposed to
their difference um
except for maybe if you're in the
radial basis function case
okay so um so this has been an active
area uh studying properties of the
vascular stein gradient flow of this
energy
um and then
one last example that i'd like to
mention that could be uh close to the
interest of people here um
is looking at a vasserstein gradient
flow of the chi-squared divergence and i
first learned about this from
philippe in his paper
with uh chewie i have all the names
chewie lagoon
mao nu and uh riley um
and in fact uh i at the same time was
working on something very similar um and
unfortunately was unable to prove it for
the exact model i had in mind but when i
switched to philippe's model it was much
better and then we were able to prove it
so this is a work in progress with
karthik ellen buzz ellen vasupi um matt
haberland and olga turanova and so um
what that's kind of the first authors
were proposing in their paper was to
consider uh the chi-squared divergence
they're given a
target
which i'll call robar
and to think about what the vossenstein
gradient flow of this is and in fact if
rho bar is identically equal to one this
is just a porous medium location which
on the pde side of things is something
that has been well studied um but for
general rhobar it becomes kind of a
spatially and homogeneous type of porous
medium equation um
and uh in this paper they propose a
particle method for discretizing it um
but as we've already discussed a few
times in this lecture um sometimes
there's a canonical particle method and
sometimes there's not and this is one of
the cases where there's not if you look
at the velocity field the rising from
this energy this is much more like the
case of diffusion where the velocity
field doesn't satisfy a global lipschitz
condition and so there's not this
natural particle method associated with
it um so instead you have to get a
little creative um and like i already
said some methods have been proposed um
but what we uh do in our current work is
we propose a different method um
which is we we regularize this energy
and this was inspired by some previous
work i had done with jose antonio
carrillo and francesco patakini we
basically sneak in a convolution kernel
with the row
and then leave the rest of the
chi-square divergence unchanged
um
and what's nice about this little trick
is suddenly if you look at the velocity
field now it does satisfy a global
ellipse bound of course one that
deteriorates with epsilon but now you
can do now this does have a natural
particle method um and what we show is
that as you remove the regularization
and refine the number of particles
indeed it converges to the continuum
gradient flow of the energy um okay so
the reason i mentioned this example is
just to show that again the vosserstein
gradient flow perspective um you know
may be of interest to you because you
one might not have guessed this method
if one hadn't been thinking about it um
thinking about what the energy looks
like and thinking of it from the
gradient flow perspective so it can
offer kind of a different way to look at
some of these problems that sometimes
can be useful
okay so the moral of what
the motivation part of my lecture was i
hope to convince you that this
vosserstein gradient flow perspective
brings new tools that would maybe
complement a pure pde or particle
technique perhaps it's outside the scope
of what they're saying but
what was the motivation for uh
cnn to study this uh
well i i don't necessarily want to
answer for you but maybe i can say a
short answer then you can jump in which
is i think they were uh they wanted to
interpret the gradient flow of the
chi-square divergence as a type of
kernelized nine variational gradient
descent
and it's a sampling procedure as the
same thing that you're doing when you do
a dcd
except that the cgp is an information
which is
okay all right so now i'm coming to the
end of the the motivation and so i'm
going to talk about the plan um for my
lecture today um so my plan is to begin
um by just doing a warm-up talking about
gradient flow in euclidean space um in
order to motivate the type of conditions
um that we need on our energies in order
for gradient flow in metric spaces or
emboss or steinmetric space to make
sense
um second i'm going to say just a few
words about the kind of historical
connection between gradient flow and pd
though a lot has already been said in
the previous lectures
but you know why pd or why gradient flow
techniques are useful and kind of have
historically been useful in pde um
then i'm going to go and start talking
about gradient flow and metric spaces
and the reason why i
wanted to go this perspective is i know
a lot of the people here come from a
background in
like geometric optimization and i think
uh you'll see many strong connections
between the metric space picture and and
the the geometric optimization lectures
we heard earlier this week and then
lastly i'll talk about what happens in a
particular case where your metric is the
boss or sign metric
okay so
let us
jump into the first topic
which is gradient flow on euclidean
space
okay so gradient flow in euclidean space
this is something that you may have seen
as in an undergraduate ordinary
differential equations class we have an
energy e defined on rd taking on
real numbers we have some initial
condition that's a real number um and in
this case a gradient flow of the energy
with initial conditions x naught is just
a solution of this ordinary differential
equation so x of t its time derivative
evolves in the direction of negative the
gradient of the energy
and at times zero it starts off these
initial conditions
okay so um
you know as
a cartoon of what's going on here i mean
though i think this is uh something uh
people here are very familiar with um is
we have some energy here so we'll think
of this as an energy defined on r2 so
the gradient flow is happening down here
in the plane and basically in order to
move in the direction of negative the
gradient what does that mean that just
means that you're moving perpendicular
to the level sets down the level sets of
the energy so if i have drawn the level
sets down there in the plane and i pick
some initial condition right here x
naught then the gradient flows just kind
of going down the level sets and
similarly if i pick some initial
condition there why not it's just going
to go kind of down the level sets in
that direction
okay
so
the reason that i drew this kind of
overly simplistic picture
is i just want to emphasize uh
the role of the metric the role of the
underlying geometry i think in gradient
flow type things we often focus a lot on
the energy
and especially when you're in euclidean
space it's easy to disregard the
underlying metric
but you see the role of the metric right
here because
gradient flow it rolls goes
perpendicular to the level sets and it's
the metric that's telling you what is
perpendicular mean and so when you that
that's you know what happens when you
when you do gradient flows of the same
energy with respect to different metrics
the energy could always be the same its
level sets are the same those are
intrinsics to the energy but what the
different metrics are telling you is
they're telling you what is
perpendicular mean in that metric what
does it mean to go down in the steepest
descent with respect to a given metric
okay so um
the first thing that as a mathematician
we would ask is when do solutions this
ordinary differential equation exists
when does this even make sense as a
mathematical model an easy sufficient
condition is just if the energy is
continuously differentiable okay you
know super we would probably hope it's
continuously differentiable if we're
taking its gradient um
and so you know the at least from there
maybe existence is not um too bad but
what happens when we start wanting to
think about things like uniqueness
and so here i would like to add actually
one extra criteria to the gradient flow
that i'm going to be studying which is
that the gradient flow is just going to
be for non-negative times
so all that i care about is my initial
condition and going forward in time i'm
not going to be wanting to go backward
in time this may not surprise you
considering that one of the gradient
flows i'm working up to is the heat
equation which is an awesome equation
forward and time and not as great
backward at time
okay so if we're trying to just now we
want to get uniqueness of solutions of
this ordinary differential equation
forward in time
so what are some
good conditions that our energy can
satisfy that would guarantee uniqueness
well again probably in your
undergraduate ordinary differential
equation class you maybe would have
learned that one of the key assumptions
for uniqueness is that this right hand
side needs to satisfy some kind of
lipschitz condition
um
and so
uh we want to put a lipschitz condition
on the right hand side on the gradient
of e
but because we only care about solutions
forward in time we can actually get away
with a one-sided lipschitz condition
uh and which is the following
uh so we're gonna require
there to exist
a number lambda
so that
if i take the inner product of x minus 5
with grad of e x
minus grad of e y
that's going to be greater than or equal
to lambda times x minus 5
squared
this has to hold for all x and y
okay so uh you can see that
if the gradient of your energy satisfied
like a full lipschitz condition
that would imply this where lambda was
negative of the lipschitz constant just
by using the koshi schwartz uh
inequality okay but this is something a
little bit weaker than a full lipsticks
condition and we really need this
weakness um you know like i said when we
go forward and start talking about
things like the heat equation
the heat equation when you think of the
analog of this and the boss or sign
space you're only going to be able to
get a one-sided lipstick estimate not a
two-sided one um and you know this
relates to the fact that you know heat
equation is fine forward and time and
you run into problems backward in time
okay so um so this is uh
a natural condition from the perspective
of you know classical ordinary
differential equations but it turns out
that this condition we've actually seen
so many times in the conference already
this turns out to be equivalent as long
as is the energy is continuously
differentiable
to
what i would call an above the tangent
line inequality
so that there exists lambda
so that
e of y minus e of x
minus gradient of v of x
times y minus x
um so if i just had greater than or
equal to zero there that would truly be
saying that the function e of y lied
above the tangent line but i'm not going
to put 0 there instead i'm going to put
um
kind of it can do to satisfy this up to
this error depending on lambda
okay so you know clearly when with
lambda is a negative number this is a
weaker hypothesis it's a positive number
it's a stronger hypothesis
thank you
so cash
functions you actually want them to be
by default you want two-sided so like
zero is like a constant function it's
not a legit function in your in your
that's
uh that's what ships
um
so i mean this one is telling me that f
of x minus f of y is lower bounded by x
minus one right
yes sorry lambda can be negative
yes yes um
okay uh
and then
um
[Music]
uh and then finally this is equivalent
to again a condition that we've seen
many times
in this workshop which is just that the
energy be lambda conducts
so there exists
some parameter lambda so that when i
evaluate my energy
along the line connecting a point x to
the point y
i can bound that above by one minus
alpha
times e of x
plus alpha e of y if i stopped here it
would just be the usual convexity
assumption but now i'm going to add this
kind of up to an error depending on
lambda
no this has to not only hold um for all
x
uh and y and rd but um for all alpha
between zero and one
so
um
why do these kind of criteria which you
know depending on what your background
is you may prefer one to the other why
do these uh imply uniqueness at the just
even in euclidean space um
so
suppose that we have two gradient flows
x of t and y of t
um we can just do a simple computation
so what i'm going to do is i'm actually
going to prove something stronger than
uniqueness i'm going to prove a
contraction in equality like we already
heard about a lot on the sampling day so
if i want to prove a contraction
inequality i want to say
i want to estimate if i have one
gradient a solution of my gradient flow
at time t and another solution of my
gradient flow at time t i want to
estimate how these solutions are either
kind of coming together or spreading
apart depending on the distance between
their initial data
um and so okay maybe first you might
think about just
looking at the time derivative of their
distance seeing if they're coming
together or going apart but nobody likes
to differentiate the absolute value so
i'm going to put a square there um so
now if i differentiate this i just first
apply the chain rule to
x of t minus y of t
and here i could put the time derivative
of x minus the time derivative of y and
i'm going to skip a step and use the
fact that i know what the time
derivatives are they're solutions of the
gradient flow so the time derivative of
x is just going to be negative gravity
of x
and the time derivative of y
would just be
negative gravity of y
minus signs
all right so if i have this
one-sided lipschitz condition
up here
so this isn't exactly what i have here
the signs here are wrong um but that's
fine i'll just multiply both sides by
negative 1 and flip the inequality and
then i can apply it exactly down here so
i can say that this is bounded above by
negative 2
times lambda
x of t
minus y of t
squared
okay and if you are the kind of person
who does these estimates all the time
now you know you're in good shape
because the time you bound you bounded
the time derivative of this quantity by
a constant times the quantity itself
why is this exactly what you want well
you can again just think back um to
maybe an undergraduate class you took in
ordinary differential equations so think
what would happen if we actually had
equality there
if you were looking at this ordinary
differential equation where some
quantity a of t
can evolve
it can evolve involves with
uh equal sign according to negative two
a of t this is a maybe one of the first
ordinary differential equations you
would encounter and it has this nice
explicit solution
in terms of the
exponential
so
on the other hand we have an inequality
here saying that it the rate at which
this
grows is bounded above by that but
that's fine what we're going to say is
worst case scenario equality holds there
so we know that the rate at which this
grows always has to be smaller than the
weight at which that is growing
um and so for that reason we know that
we have that x of t minus y of t
always has to be
bounded above
by the rate at which this
um
other ode was growing
and then i can cancel out my squares
okay so this gives me
a contraction inequality for example if
lambda is positive
i know that as time goes on that's going
to go to zero
and so
i
whatever my initial conditions are as
time goes on my solutions are going to
approach each other on the other hand if
lambda is negative
this is at least giving me a stability
estimate it's telling me that if my
initial conditions are so far apart the
resulting solutions of my gradient flow
can be at most those times this apart
another thing that you so a consequence
of that is that it gives us uniqueness
if the initial conditions are the same
then x of t has to equal y of t for all
t greater than or equal to zero so
that's why this um one-sided ellipse
condition is exactly what we need to get
uniqueness
one last thing to point out is that
let's assume that we have a
and a strictly convex energy so it's
lambda convex for lambda positive with a
unique so to have a unique global
minimizer then you know that if you
initialize your gradient flow at the
unique global minimizer it will just
stay there for all time
and so that y of t would just always
equal the global minimizer and in that
case this gives us an estimate on the
rate of convergence to the global
minimizer and exponential rate of
convergence okay
so um
okay so a few uh
quick remarks um
uh
i think
i will just make a very uh small comment
that while uh
let's see so yeah first let me talk
let's talk about what a little bit more
intuition behind this one-sided
lipschitz condition
uh first if my energy is actually
content twice continuously
differentiable these conditions are
equivalent to the hesh having a lower
bound on the hessian
i really like thinking about it this way
and even if your energy is not twice
continuously differentiable you can look
at generalized notions of passion and
this perspective kind of really makes
sense with my brain somehow lambda
conductivity is giving you
a lower bound on the hessian it's a
negative lower bound if lambda is
negative
strictly positive or bounded that is
positive
um something that you can see sort of
immediately when you think about things
from this perspective is that if you
have an energy that's lambda naught
convex and another energy oh that should
be e sub one
uh that's lambda one convex
then their sum
is going to be lambda naught plus lambda
1 and x okay so
this convexity property behaves nice
when you take sums um of course as i
already said when lambda is strictly
positive this is
what is often known as being strongly
convex
um and then the last comment i want to
make is that
the third
third characterization of this the
lambda convexity characterization we
evaluated the energy on a line
connecting x to y
along this line and i just want to point
out that that line right there is the
geodesic from x to y in in euclidean
space um when you're working in
different metrics you will use the
geodesic and that metric um so that's
probably something that seems familiar
for those coming on from the geometric
optimization side
um
okay so
uh
one last convexity comment
sometimes
so what's nice about these uniqueness
assumptions is you get to pick the
lambda in particular
if you can do it for a lambda negative
that's great it's it's you could still
get a lot of information you're not
going to get you know exponential
conversions equilibrium but you're still
going to get great stability estimates
um but sometimes you can't even prove
something like this for any lambda uh
and you know this happens a lot when
you're looking at a borderline case on
the the pde side um and so i just want
to make a remark that there's another
notion of convexity here you can think
about a different modulus of convexity
so
instead of this x minus y here i'm going
to replace that with the function omega
of x minus y and the point here is you
get to choose the lambda and you get to
choose the omega though of course there
are some
constraints of which you can choose for
omega
omega x
uh has to be some continuous
increasing function
and
equals zero at zero so popular choices
of
uh omega x in practice
uh and actually in fact we need a few
more assumptions which i'll say in a
second but some popular choices are okay
of course if i just take omega x equals
x
this reduces to that
but i could also choose omega of x
is x log x
and in this case if lambda is negative
this is a strictly weaker hypothesis
than semiconducting so you can have an
energy that fails semi-convexity but
could still satisfy this
um or you could also do a polynomial
modulus of convexity
for some p greater than one
and i wrote it here because it's maybe
cleanest but there are exact analogs of
this on that characterization and in
that characterization
um so what does this mean when we come
down to this
contraction any quality that we proved
well if we take this
long glitch it's modulus of convexity
it turns out to give us a double
exponential rate so the right hand side
i'll becomes
uh
x naught
minus x naught minus my y naught to the
power two lambda t
so
if lambda is positive this is a really
fast rate of convergence to equilibrium
but of course you know most of the time
you prove this because lambda is
negative and you're trying to get
something weaker than some convexity
on the other hand if you take a
polynomial modulus of continuity
then the right hand side looks a bit
complicated but it's basically gives you
a polynomial estimate on convergence to
equilibrium
and so i mentioned this because
of course we all wish we could get
exponential convergence to equilibrium
but sometimes you can't and sometimes
you know you have examples that prove
that that's impossible
but maybe you could still hope for a
polynomial convergence to equilibrium or
in that case you might consider trying
to prove a convexity inequality with
this polynomial modulus of continuity or
similarly on the other side maybe you
know there's no hope of you know
exponential or even polynomial converges
to equilibrium you know you have a
non-convex energy landscape but you
would just kill for a stability estimate
um maybe there's no hope of a stability
estimate along these lines but maybe
there's a hope of a stability estimate
along these lines for a negative value
of lambda
um
good question i dropped the e
thank you
thank you
typo important typo yes so it's this to
the power e to the two lambda t
okay so
all right so
gradient flow and euclidean space this
is something that a lot of us
have a lot of experience with but how
does this nice gradient flow theory on
euclidean space have any hope of
extending to a general metric space um
so i want to talk about two
other attributes of gradient flow on
euclidean space that will help us
generalize geometric space
and the first is called the energy
dissipation equality and this is kind of
a fancy and overly fancy name probably
in the euclidean case um it's just
pointing out
that
being a solution of my yes
question does semiconvexity plus c1
implies existence
of the
existence
uh yes and
in fact um uh just c one implies a
global existence
that's one
but she wants to go out in feet right
because you could take e of x minus
you're right sorry
and i guess i haven't i've been
neglecting any sorts of um
concerns at infinity yes uh
exactly see for example if you have some
sort of quadratic growth any type of
coercivity at infinity or lower bound
yes yes thank you
um
okay
uh
so um okay so here's our gradient flow
uh
so what is this saying this is saying
that uh x of t
it
the time derivative of x points in the
direction of negative the gradient of
the energy so in other words this vector
in this vector they have the same
magnitude but they point in different
directions
so we can write that as they have the
same magnitude
and then we can write the fact that they
point in different directions
actually kind of
we can sneak that into the chain rule
so we know that this always would equal
you know again sufficient regularity on
e
the gradient of e taking the inner
product with x of t
and the gradient of e when you take the
inner product with x of t
by koshi schwarz inequality that's
always going to be greater than or equal
to uh
negative the product of their magnitudes
and equality will only hold if they
point in opposite directions
okay so
this ensures that they're pointing in
opposite directions and this ensures
that they have uh that they have the
same length so that these two
requirements are equivalent to that one
and then
lastly we can use this fact
that
if you take the the product of two real
numbers a and b this is always going to
be
greater than or equal to negative a
squared over 2 minus b squared over 2
with equality
only if
a equals b
and so because of that these two
equalities here
are actually equivalent
thank you
uh are actually equivalent to
requiring that this be less than or
equal to
negative one-half
radiant to this
minus negative one-half
dot of t
because the other inequality always
holds and the only way for this to hold
is if actually um this equals opposite
of that
okay so
um
so why did i go through this uh it turns
out that while the left-hand side here
is something that it's really using
gradients you know gradients make sense
in euclidean space they make sense on a
romanian manifold but we don't generally
have a notion of gradient and arbitrary
metric space the quantities here
are all going to be things that we can
make sense of in an arbitrary metric
space
okay actually
yes are there like examples where like
on metric stages where there's like ed
well it's in a non-trivial way but that
metric space doesn't admit like a
remodeling structure at least morally
um
so
do there exists so yeah we can talk
about this a little bit more in a moment
but i think
i'll define a notion of curve of maximal
slope on a metric space and i think your
question is do there exist curves of
maximal slope on metric spaces
which lack romanian structures
is that your question uh yeah i guess
like um you know the main example i have
in mind is like buster's had ingredient
flows for this but um of course faster
science space at least like formally
does have a remarkable structure so i
was just wondering
what actual generality do you get from
this setup
you can define a curve of maximal slope
on an arbitrary complete metric space
do they always exist uh uh yes you i
mean i they're i i guess i'm it's gonna
be hard for me to come up with an
explicit example on the spot but yes we
could think of a metric space where a
curve a maximal slope exists um is
unique and that that metric space does
not have a romanian structure but um
on the flip side you still it
i think your intuition is right in the
sense that
i'm going to spend a lot of time today
talking about curves maximum slope on
metric spaces which are super but you
don't always have a very nice
characterization of them like what's so
great about the foster science gradient
flows is that you have these multiple
equivalent characterization of the same
things and that gives you so many tools
to attack them for a curve on a general
metric space i'll define what it means
to be a curve of maximal slope great
you'll know this inequality holds but
unless you have a lot of the same
ingredients as in the vostojn case and
i'll talk about what ingredients those
are you're not going to have a nice
differential equation characterization
of that gradient flow
maybe just a comment i don't know if i
understood
so uh
you were also asking does there exist
sometimes some something it has a decent
uh uh great infrastructure but the
uh some of the remaining aspects of it
doesn't really work
and uh let's say me curvature flow is an
example of that so if you look at uh
sets and your energy is the parameter
right and then your metric is uh
the l2 norm of the velocity integrated
along the parameters right then
uh this has a formal gradient flow
structure yet the geometry on the space
of curves right and this is proved by
montreal in 2005. it generates the name
of the distance between any two curves
is zero right there
there are
paths of arbitrarily small like yet the
alpha grid infrastructure is still
useful in some ways
okay so i think because we're coming to
the end of this first
part i'm going to leave this time
discretization to the next part so when
we come back after the break i'll say a
little bit about time discretization for
gradient flows in euclidean space and
then we will jump into the metric space
context thank you
questions
up